okay I've got something very special for
us today previously we've done these
giveaways of memberships we're a Good
Samaritan viewer or listener we'll say
David I want to sponsor some memberships
or I'll pay for half of a bunch of
people's memberships and then they can
get them at half-price and usually it's
just as I call them good Samaritans
random people we actually have something
very special today which is that the
musical artist deep glass has decided to
sponsor some memberships in the name of
their latest self-titled album also
called deep glass which you can find at
cdbaby.com or on itunes links will
appear in the video description for the
youtube clip for this story deep glass
is a progressive musical act and they
are doing something really awesome
which is actually they're doing two very
cool things number one they've already
paid for half of 20 memberships okay
half of 20 yearly memberships a normal
yearly membership with all the perks the
bonus show the commercial free audio
feed the commercial free video feed all
that great stuff it normally cost $60
deep glass has already paid $30 for
twenty memberships meaning that 20
people who want to get a membership for
half price can do it by writing in you
go to david pakman.com you click on the
contact page and you say I want one of
those deep glass memberships these this
will run until the 20 memberships are
spoken for right in I'll send you a
coupon code if you're one of the first
20 and that's a really really great
thing but in addition to that for every
album sold between now and when the
memberships run out deep glass will
donate three dollars to the Institute
for Women's policy research so basically
three different things here number one
if you want one of the half-price
memberships just right in they've
already paid 30 bucks so you can get the
membership for 30 bucks and you can keep
that discounted rate for as long as you
want that alone is a really big thing
number two please check out the album
deep glass buy deep glass on iTunes or
on cdbaby.com just checking out the
album also helps them more streams it is
good please do that and number three if
you choose to buy the album they will
also donate $3 for every album sold to
the Institute for Women's policy
research first-come first-served twenty
half-price memberships thanks to deep
glass the new self-titled album also
called deep glass this is cool this is
something different I like the stuff you
know and half of 20 memberships does not
mean ten memberships no that's right
it's 20 memberships at half price yes
what I need a grammatically ambiguous
promo but a good promo nonetheless so
get in touch twenty memberships left
right now I'll keep you posted on how
many remain